[Music]
welcome back to science click today
space-time rotations
we live in a geometric space in which we
can move turn measure lengths or angles
each person has their own frame of
reference
a unique point of view of the universe
of which we are the center and through
which we locate objects around us
taking this person's frame of reference
for example the car is moving
but in the driver's frame of reference
it is the person on looking which moves
frames of reference describe the
universe from a given point of view
three axes are enough left right up down
forward backward
at the beginning of the 20th century
this Paradigm was turned on its head
when we understood that time is actually
a fourth dimension of the universe
there is a fourth axis which must be
taken into account
in this video we will try to explain
this revolution which has since allowed
scientists to unify space and time but
also the electric and magnetic fields or
momentum and energy
[Music]
let's imagine a street in which a person
a is standing on the sidewalk and a
person B is driving a car
the car moves forwards relative to the
street and to describe its motion we
will construct a space-time diagram
to do this we freeze each instant
and stack the images on top of one
another
they thus form a block which represents
the flow of time
in this block the two persons move
towards the future each drawing their
own world line
person a follows a straight line towards
the future while person B who is moving
traces a tilted path
each slice of the diagram pinpoints
their location at a given time
at this stage the situation is described
from the point of view of the road in
the reference frame of person a
what would the diagram look like if we
ask the driver to draw it from his point
of view
in his reference frame B is at the
center of the universe
to form his diagram we must therefore
shift all slices one after the other to
replace him at the center of the scene
the car is now Motionless
and it is person a who seems to be
moving backwards
we have just performed a Galilean
transformation
Shifting the slices of space allows us
to change our frame of reference
in this way physicists understood as
early as the 17th century that motion
depends on the Observer for a B is in
motion but for B it is a who moves
neither of these two statements is more
valid than the other motion is relative
if B decides to throw a ball
the speed of the ball will seem faster
for a since it is moving with the car
according to Galileo we can add up
velocities to change reference frames
while this idea may seem natural and
intuitive a discovery made at the dawn
of the 20th century came to question it
all
imagine that A and B both turn on a
flashlight
neglecting the presence of the air which
slows it down light escapes from the two
lamps at 299 million 792
458 meters per second
viewed from the road we would expect
that the ray launched by B moves
slightly faster since it should add to
the motion of the car
however against all expectations the two
beams have exactly the same speed
with astonishment physicists discovered
that this precise speed is absolute any
object moving at 299 million 792
458 meters per second will have this
exact speed in all reference frames it
is called the speed of light
this finding came as a drastic shock
how is it possible that this speed does
not add up to that of the car
why unlike the ball thrown by B earlier
does light not change speed from one
frame to another
to grasp the extent of the problem
imagine that a emits one light Ray on
each side
in her reference frame both Rays have
the same speed
but in B's reference frame the diagram
becomes slanted
for him light should move faster in One
Direction than the other
and yet it Remains the Same
the solution to this Paradox will be
found at the beginning of the 20th
century for the speed of light to remain
constant in accordance with observations
the diagram must be distorted by
shifting not only slices of space but
also slices of time
this manipulation is the only one
allowing us to change reference frame
while preserving the speed of light in
both directions and without distorting
either straight lines or the volumes of
the diagram
we call this a Lorenz transformation
the idea behind it is shocking time and
space warp and change direction
depending on the Observer
the duration between events
the order in which they occur and even
the length of objects become relative
measurements which change from one point
of view to another
these two events for instance occur one
second apart in this first frame
but 1.1 Seconds Apart in this other
frame
and the car is four meters long in its
own frame
but slightly shorter in the frame of the
road
when a body moves relative to us its
clock seems to tick in slow motion and
its length seems contracted
this is special relativity
let's slightly digress for one moment
viewed from above a city can be depicted
on a map that identifies the layout of
its Road Network
if we rotate this map the position and
direction of the roads seem to change
this is just an illusion the orientation
of the map is arbitrary it is an
abstract description of the world which
does not impact reality
physicists quickly made the analogy
between the space-time diagram and the
map
like a map our diagram is only an
abstract representation of the universe
and like with a map we can change our
point of view to look at it
in other words the Lawrence
Transformations which allow us to switch
reference frames are somewhat equivalent
to the rotations of our map
this idea makes sense because like
rotations Lawrence Transformations
preserve straight lines and volumes
but unlike classic rotations Lawrence
Transformations seem to distort the
diagram they do not preserve distances
between points some move away While
others get closer
and while rotations draw circles
they draw hyperbolas
[Music]
how could such Transformations be
equivalent to rotations
the genius idea to explain this will be
brought by ponkari and minkowski they
invented a new way of measuring
distances within the diagram the
minkowsky metric
according to them our diagram is
abstract and does not Faithfully
represent real distances through
space-time somewhat like a world map
which deforms the surface of the Earth
to make it flat
even though it may not look like it all
the points which make up a hyperbola
would actually be the same distance from
the center
the hyperbola would be the analog of a
circle the curve whose points are all
the same distance from the center
by changing frame of reference All
Points slide along these hyperbolas
while remaining at the same distance
from the center
thanks to the minkowsky metric the
analogy becomes perfect and the Lawrence
Transformations are indeed analogous to
rotations they are hyperbolic rotations
unlike a classic rotation which can turn
in all directions a hyperbolic rotation
distinguishes two types of directions on
the one hand durations which can be
brought onto the time axis
and on the other hand lengths which can
be brought onto the space axis
durations and lengths are intervals of a
different nature intervals of time or of
space and light rays form a cone which
separates them fundamentally
whatever the frame of reference a
duration remains a duration and a length
remains a length
hence since each Observer advances
towards their own future it is
impossible to go back in time we are
confined Within These light cones and in
all frames of reference the future
Remains the future
a classic rotation always ends up
looping on itself after 360 degrees but
a hyperbolic rotation can rotate
indefinitely because the angle of the
rotation is no longer measured along a
circle but along a hyperbola which
extends to Infinity
we can thus rotate space-time as much as
we want
the angle of a space-time rotation is
called rapidity it measures how fast one
frame of reference moves relative to
another
the rapidity of the car for instance is
the angle between its own frame and that
of the road
if the car accelerates its rapidity
increases
if it accelerates for an infinitely long
time it would end up reaching the speed
of light
thus the speed of light actually amounts
to an infinite rapidity it is the
maximum speed that an object could only
reach in theory when accelerating for an
infinitely long time
light is infinitely fast
when B throws a ball it is not its
velocity or its speed which are added to
that of the vehicle but its rapidity
thus when B emits light
the speed of the car does not add on
since the rapidity of light is already
infinite
by revealing all these Concepts
physicists have gradually discovered the
geometry of space-time far from being an
abstract diagram space-time is now a
physical entity endowed with distances
and rotations
this new vision has allowed scientists
to understand that time and space are
only dimensions of a single object
space-time
space-time allows us to better
understand the notion of acceleration
for instance an object is said to
accelerate when its motion is altered by
changing either speed or Direction
in space-time we understand that these
two cases are both rotations a classical
rotation or a hyperbolic rotation
accelerating actually amounts to Turning
within space time
space-time also unifies electric and
magnetic fields
an electric field generates a force
which accelerates charged particles
while a magnetic field generates a force
that makes them turn
these two situations are in fact
analogous just like the magnetic field
the electric field makes particles turn
only with hyperbolic rotations within
space time
the electric field is the time version
of the magnetic field
finally this Vision allows us to unify
the Notions of momentum and energy
energy is actually the time version of
momentum
while one measures movement through
space the other measures movement
Through Time
a stationary object for example has no
momentum it does not move through space
but it has energy because it moves
through time towards the future
if the object accelerates its speed
changes it turns within space time and
gains both momentum and energy
by approaching the speed of light these
two quantities tend to Infinity
Lawrence Transformations are only
abstract rotations of our map of the
universe changes of reference frame
which don't affect the true geometry of
space-time
in the Years following these
breakthroughs Einstein and his
contemporaries will discover that
space-time can in fact get distorted
explaining the phenomenon of gravity
theory of general relativity is born
however special relativity was not
abandoned for all that just like the
Earth which is curved but seems flat on
a small scale space-time is still
adequately described on a small scale by
the minkowsky metric the basis of our
understanding of the universe today new
theories are trying to understand this
geometry at the fundamental scale is
space-time perfectly smooth or rather
cut up into small grains Does it include
more Dimensions which could be curled up
and therefore invisible at our scale
or maybe it fluctuates with quantum
agitations
ideas and theories abound in the hope of
one day achieving a fundamental
understanding of the universe
[Music]